[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur ce plateau de
la grande interview avec comme première
invitée en cette rentrée jean yves
bertheau bonjour bonjour bonjour
monsieur l'ambassadeur vous publiez un
livre qui sort cet siobhan
déjeuner avec les talibans alors on voit
la couverture on voit ce livre déjeuner
au pluriel 1 c'est très important parce
que vous avez passé beaucoup de temps
avec que vous avez fait une grande
partie de votre carrière dans le monde
arabo musulman notamment à kaboul comme
chef de poste et en ambassadeurs c'est
quoi votre parcours vous avez connu tous
les régimes de l'afghanistan j'ai vu en
effet ce pays au début de son calvaire
contemporain puisque ce calvaire a
commencé avec la révolution communiste
de
1978 qui aboutit au gouvernement qu'il
n'y arrivait pas qui était évidemment
très soutenue par les soviétiques mais
ça ne marchait pas donc insurrection
finalement nous lever par les
soviétiques partie russe l'arrivée des à
l'arrivée des rues l'arrivée des russes
pour pouvoir revenir à la résonance de
ce gouvernement incapable et
l'incapacité des russes à faire face à
une rébellion
insupportable sur le plan humain sur le
plan économique et qui donc commence
déjà à partir de 79 80 après sylvain 80
plutôt a précipité le pays dans la
misère il a toujours connu depuis depuis
43 ans que dure cette guerre civile j'ai
vu donc je suis parti après en 81 à ce
moment là j'étais jeune secrétaire
d'ambassade je suis retourné
en vingt ans plus tard au moment où les
talibans sont arrivés on cherchait
quelqu'un qui connaissait l'afghanistan
pour être conseiller politique d'une
mission de l'onu sur place pour trouver
d un règlement politique entre les
taliban et l'alliance du nord
et ensuite j'ai dirigé l'ambassade et
j'ai continué à parler non seulement
avec les talibans mais aussi avec tous
les protagonistes
de l'époque c'est nadia le commandant
massoud l'ancien roi zaher shah
etc et tous les grands commandants les
oppositions de toutes sortes mais vous
avez assisté à
cette fabrication d'une machine
terroriste y exporter le terrorisme à
l'international 1 puisque après les
attentats du 11 septembre aux états unis
vous avez vu arriver des américains
j'étais là non je suis parti umma
aliments se sont effondrés évidemment
j'ai suivi les affaires afghanes depuis
et je retrace ça dans mon dans mon
ouvrage bien entendu est ce que vous
êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
pas de 20 ans d'occupation américaines
pas du tout pas du tout c'était attendu
de toute façon on savait que les
talibans étaient en train de revenir sur
le terrain depuis déjà des années
parce que bon ils ont ce qui a été
balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans c'est
al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001 et al
qaïda et aux talibans ce ne sont pas
deux concepts superposables les talibans
avaient pris le pouvoir c'était des gens
très épris d'une interprétation
extraordinairement rigoureuse et
réductrice du coran mais tout est le
deuxième mode théorie je nuancerais ça
je dirais parmi les talibans il ya pu y
avoir et des éléments qui n'étaient pas
en accord avec la ligne nationaliste et
non j à dist des talibans ceux là ont
rejoint ont pu rejoindre al-qaïda ont pu
rejoindre d'autres groupuscules
achèterait ch
alassane et ses neurones l exportation
des djihadistes qui prenait exportations
les talibans leur idéologie elle et elle
est tout aussi fondamentalistes
attention que ceux des djihadistes mais
il ne souhaite pas du tout exporter
leurs modèles faille non ils n'ont
jamais rien mis en oeuvre pour tenter de
l'exporter
évidemment
lorsque
leur la communauté internationale sait
si vivement opposés à eux parce que les
talibans se tirait eux mêmes une balle
dans le pied avec leurs exactions
vis-à-vis d'une femme l'homme
d'exagération de 2 de toutes sortes leur
comportement qui parfois toucher au
ridicule et au scandale bon évidemment
la communauté internationale a réagi
comme on pouvait comprendre qu'elles
puissent réagir c'est à dire à part des
sanctions mais ces sanctions en fait ont
eu un effet l'effet inverse de celui que
la cambrure asphyxié d'une passe à
radicaliser encore bien sûr appauvrit la
population mais surtout ça a convaincu
ceux des talibans qui cherchait le
dialogue avec la communauté
internationale soit je parlais avec tous
les ministres à l'est et donc je voyais
bien que certains d'entre eux étaient
très partisan d'un dialogue était tout à
fait désireux aussi de donner des signes
de faire des signaux de faire des
aménagements j'avais obtenu par exemple
que les queues à la suite d'une
conversation avec lui la santé que les
femmes puissent se voir ouvrir certains
hôpitaux alors qu'avant il leur était
fermé oui donc on voyait bien qu'il y
avait certains signes encourageants
parmi une frange parce que vous savez
l'afghanistan c'est un pays déjà
géographiquement
morcelée si on ne comprend pas la
géographie de l'afghanistan avec ce
morcellement que donnent les montagnes
les vallées etc qui depuis des
millénaires ont fabriqué des identités
très léger réalisés et donc chaque
région à fabriquer sa propre culture ces
codes etc et donc on retrouve ça chez
les talibans comme chez tous les autres
avant les tellement c'est un mouvement
qui s'est opposé à
au gouvernement de la république des
moudjahidine qui avait chassé les
soviétiques parce que ces gens étaient
corrompus parce qu'ils avaient des
moeurs corrompu et parce qu'il était
corrompu sur le plan pécuniaire c'est à
dire que toutes les occasions étaient
bonnes pour rançonner pillés violés et c
est donc les talibans
pensaient être eu les purs ceux qui au
nom de la religion allait nettoyer tout
ça oui alors donc vous raconter tout ça
dans votre livre et quand vous dites
j'étais fortement partisans des
dialogues que j'ai essayé de d'un sip et
vous l'êtes encore aujourd'hui ça c'est
un débat d'actualité 1 go pose des
occidentaux entre eux parce que les uns
sont ne sont pas d'accord ou désolé avec
avec avec les talibans question est ce
que ces talibans qui arrivent là sur ce
que vous aviez rencontré ben c'est à la
fois les mêmes et pas les mêmes et jeudi
à leur idéologie est identique leur
idéologie est une réelle bien sûr
puisque leur idéologie se résumer en
trois mots c'est le coran rien que le
coran tout le coran de toute façon ça ne
va pas changer ça ne changera pas mais
cela dit il ya des centaines de millions
de musulmans dans le monde oki c'est
rigoureusement la même chose et avec
lesquels on s'entend très bien donc donc
il faut négocier avec eux au journalisme
bien sûr quel but exactement mais il ya
plusieurs bulles de ne pas
surtout dans les circonstances présentes
on voit que la population afghane a
tellement souffert il faut penser à
cette population donc le dialogue un
dialogue qui permette de dire nos lignes
rouges et de les encourager à ne pas
franchir
un dialogue aussi avec des arguments
nous avons qui sont aussi des arguments
sonnants et trébuchants
parce qu'il ya de l'argent qui
appartient ou à l'afghanistan qui est
bloqué la banque centrale américaine à
la résidence entre à l'américaine et
rieur ya la banque mondiale
donnez-vous au fmi et cetera ce sont là
des leviers
de négociation et de dissuasion mais
aussi des négociations négocier aussi
pour protéger un certain nombre il reste
des français en afghanistan aujourd'hui
lorsque le reste très bien des
entreprises françaises en afghanistan
quelques-unes mais très peu un très
peureuse il faut rapatrier tout ça il
faut voir les ponts aériens sont
maintenant rompu oui mais enfin tout ça
est en train de se mettre en place il ya
toujours des discussions comme vous le
savez à doha avec les talibans qui
entonnait des signes à qui ont donné des
assurances puisque que ces mouvements de
personnes pourraient être facilitées on
l'est on verra à leur actif il est
certain que bon on espère bien qu'ils
vont tenir leur parole mais ça ne peut
pas l'affirmer à ce stade et ça ce sera
déjà une première étape à partir de
laquelle on pourra définir
dans quelles conditions un dialogue
ultérieure mourra ce fait on aura besoin
de parler avec eux pour plein de raisons
donc on doit parler
vaut aussi le bienfait des populations
parce que dans les semaines qui viennent
on va assister à un raz-de-marée
humanitaire absolument sans presser la
vague migratoire note qui inquiète tout
le monde le risque d'une vague
migratoire de migration
fondée elle est fondée bien les fondée
aussi mais je parle mois de cela la
situation la toute première urgence et
la fin la fin ils n'ont rien à manger
mais c'est à dire que là pour l'instant
les banques sont fermées les gens ne
peut plus accéder à pâtir et salaires ne
sont pas payés il n'y a pas encore
d'état donc voilà on est dans une
période de crise c'est ce qu'on appelle
une crise c'est une période
intermédiaire entre une situation et une
autre est donc cette crise il va falloir
comment elle est dépassée et seuls les
talibans sont en mesure de montrer leur
orientation et de démontrer leur
éventuelle bonne volonté entre
guillemets par rapport à l'occident donc
tous ces signaux l'arbre il va falloir
beaucoup d étudier les analyses et les
interpréter et en tirer les conclusions
politiques qui s'imposent alors vous
nous avez dit qu'ils étaient ses gags
ces talibans qui sont un peu les mêmes
que ceux que vous aviez connu sont leurs
enfants ou leurs frères mais quelle est
la différence aujourd'hui entre les
talibans et les jeunes d'esch et les
joues les gens d'al qaïda d'abord ceux
qui ceux dont on pense qu'ils sont en
train de fomenter un certain nombre de
d'attentats notamment à l'aéroport pour
empêcher ou ce qu'ils ont fait pour
essayer d'empêcher les départs d'abord
je voudrais faire la différence entre
les talibans d'avant et les talibans de
maintenant c'est la question que posait
oui c'est ça et donc la seule je disais
tout à l'heure le coran rien que le
coran tout le corps au brun très bien
mais à part ça ce qui s'est passé c'est
que l'homme
ap lé afghan a connu des bouleversements
sur le plan sociétal et culturel
tellement important il a plus changé pas
dans les villes en tout cas parce que
l'éducation qui est passée par là le
modèle occidental et réseaux sociaux les
téléphones portables et j'en passe donc
en fait les talibans qui était là il ya
20 ans vont retrouver
aujourd'hui la moderne aujourd'hui une
forme de modernité une forme de
modernité en tout cas dans les villes
qui évidemment dont ils sont stupéfaits
parce que d'abord il ne la connaissent
pas eux mêmes je parle des combattants
en revanche oui chef en revanche j'ai
chef au now qui sont à doha depuis deux
ans à discuter tant six agrès 15
américains qu'avec leur opposition et
bien cela bien entendu on comprit
intellectuellement que la société avait
changé et que ils ne pourront pas renier
par cette espèce de terreur quotidienne
qu'il les avait tellement désigne à la
vindicte de l'opinion internationale
il y à 27 au kivu se retrouver en
opposition avec les gens dès qu'ils
seront obligés avait de toute façon dont
ils sont en opposition totale ça c'est
le deuxième volet de votre question
évidemment les talibans et des choix n'a
strictement rien à voir de la même façon
que les talibans et al-qaïda ça n'a rien
à voir non plus ce sont des ennemis
jurés
des considère que les talibans ils sont
des nationalistes afghans n'étant pas
jihadistes sont des ennemis des traîtres
à abattre et donc c'est pourquoi on a
une confrontation sanglante à kaboul qui
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui risque de
guerre civile oui ma mère mais oui mais
la différence c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
talibans sont maîtres du pays depuis
deux semaines donc s'il va se passer ils
sont équipés ils sont suréquipés ils ont
tous les moyens ils ont des services de
renseignement qui fonctionne et donc je
pense qu'on a de quelques raisons
d'espérer au moins que les talibans mais
tabac
les djihadistes qui parce que ces
djihadistes ont fait des crimes
épouvantables temps en afghanistan qu'à
l'extérieur ville qu'au pakistan et là
on a un enjeu désormais depuis c'est
terrible et clôtures de l'aéroport de
kaboul un enjeu qui dépasse désormais
l'afghanistan et qui englobe à la fois
le pakistan qui peut se retrouver aux
prises avec avec ce mouvement de dèche
dans le khorasan de l'état islamique du
khorassan mais aussi les républiques de
d'asie centrale qui sont au nord de
l'afghanistan monsieur l'ambassadeur on
s'arrête trois minutes et on reprend ce
récit passionnant dont vous avez écrit
une grande partie de ses racines dans
vous dans vos déjeuners avec les
talibans aux éditions saint-simon tu
dans trois secondes
[Musique]
bien on se retrouve sur le plateau de la
grande interview avec gilberto l'ancien
ambassadeur en afghanistan qui publie
cette semaine un livre de ces déjeuners
avec les les talibans dans lesquelles il
fait un certain nombre de révélations
mais surtout il nous brosse un tableau
sur la façon dont ce pays a fonctionné
d'où ce peuple a fonctionné sur ce point
là monsieur l'ambassadeur il ya une
chose qui a beaucoup étonné les
occidentaux c'est la facilité avec
laquelle les talibans ont pris le
pouvoir en afghanistan et la rapidité
avec laquelle on a l'impression que le
peuple les attendait on a l'impression
que le peuple leur a ouvert les portes y
compris à kaboul oui bien sûr bon les
dunes par l'armée visiblement n'était
pas extraordinairement motif il ya une
itinérance forme et ça c'est une chose
le président en place n'a pas été très
courageux le président a fait preuve
d'une couardise abominable s'est enfui
il s'est enfui et j'ai appris par des
sources de kaboul les circonstances dans
lesquelles ça s'est passé parce qu'à un
moment donné les talibans ont envoyé un
message disant on est d'accord pour
rester à l'extérieur de kaboul bon
kaboul était un peu comme un fruit mûr
prêt à tomber à subir une bataille la
dernière bataille et mais en disant vous
donne des garanties pour votre sécurité
on peut engager d'ores et déjà des
pourparlers pour le fameux gouvernement
inclusif dont on parle ce qui
permettrait de sauver la face un peu et
de présenter un gouvernement qui ne
serait pas que talibans et il était à ce
moment là en train de déjeuner le
président avec un certain nombre de ses
collaborateurs
il a à ce moment là blêmit quittait la
table et s'est réfugié dans une autre
pièce sous prétexte qu'il avait mal à la
tête et qui voulait se reposer pendant
20 minutes 20 minutes pendant lesquelles
il a
demander à ce qu'on nomme embarque un
certain nombre de grosse valise qui
contenait 169 millions de dollars sauf
enbil 169 millions de dollars en billets
de banque et des partis à l'aéroport et
comme l'avion ne pouvait pas contenir
toutes les valises il ya une partie qui
est resté sur le tarmac de l'aéroport et
quelqu'un m'a dit que témoin visuel lui
avait rapporté avec 45 millions de
dollars sur le tarmac alors ça dont je
c'est étonnant ce que vous dites je
crois que ça a joué un rôle très
important
il dit coupe documents dans la façon
dont le gouvernement tout d'un coup cela
déliter et pourquoi est ce qu'il a fait
ça parce que si ils avaient préparé
c'était les économies de sa corruption
depuis un certain temps donc s'il a fait
ça c'était pour pouvoir
ensuite parce que s'il avoue ne
l'arrivée des talibans les talibans ils
n'auraient pas eu l'occasion de faire
partir ces périodes bien sûr vous nous
dites que les que le peuple savait tout
ça et ne supportait pas sauver leur le
peuple ne savais pas ça alors vu dans ta
clé mais le pape savait le peuple
n'ignoraient rien de la corruption de ce
gouvernement tout entier oui mais voilà
à vous mr donc simuler la grande erreur
donc il ne peut pas penser que les
taliban pouvesle ray leur assurer une
autre c'est un bis repetita de ce qui
s'est passé 25 ans avant c'est à dire
qu'il ya 25 ans les moudjahidine
s'étaient partagé le pays 1 et c'est
parti moudjahidine c'était très mal
comporté en mettant le pays en coupe
réglée et et voilà que après la chute
des talibans
les américains voyant de façon
bienveillante est bien loin de ten que
ça pouvait être une bonne idée que de
faire une sorte de rassemblement avec
les chefs moudjahidines
et puis les gens qui venaient de
l'étranger etc mais malheureusement
c'est l'appât du gain qui l'a emporté la
plupart des avants sont restés si
misérable et dans les campagnes les
talibans c'est pour ça qu'ils ont gagné
du terrain si vite réagi et ont été
accueillie avec bonheur oui à kaboul ce
n'est pas le cas tu envisages évidemment
parce que les gens vont me dire mais
enfin vous voyez bien les images les
femmes de kaboul ne sont pas bien sûr
que non en effet dans les villes san et
toute une autre affaire il était le
peuple ne peut que souffrir affreusement
de voir arriver ces gens qui n'ont pas
les mêmes moeurs que les personnes et du
clae mais monsieur l'ambassadeur comment
va vivre le peuple afghan aujourd'hui
soit dans les campagnes ou même dans les
villes il ya plus d'argent les banques
sont fermées et à terme ce pays ne
vivaient que de deux choses 1 l'aide
internationale
ce que laissaient les américains sur
place et puis le commerce de la drogue
la drogue c'est 90% du marché mondial
ouais hein on n'en parle pas au l'opium
et ses dérivés on n'en parle pas on en
parle et je crois que c'est une des
raisons naturellement il ya donc comme
je commençais à le dire tout à l'heure
et plusieurs raisons parler avec les
talibans il ya l'aspect humanitaire la
fin get ce pays dans les toutes
prochaines semaines donc les magasins
n'y a rien dans les magasins mais c'est
tout vidé et puis a plus d'argent non
plus un bond c'est catastrophique
donc il va y avoir des que non pas
seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là évident il est bien évident que
la communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
que c'est notre devoir moral que de
venir en aide à ce peuple qui a souffert
tant par le passé par les communistes
par les moudjahidine par les talibans
puis par ces corrompus puis à nouveau
par les talibans et donc il est
absolument indispensable de faire
quelque chose alors pour ça on fait
comment les les ong et les ong elles ont
besoin qu'il y ait des forces politiques
qui leur viennent parfois renaître en
taisant les difficultés c'était l'un de
mes objectifs
que de parler avec les talibans à
l'époque c'était aussi par quand y avait
des crises souvent pour des vétilles
avec les terrains c'était de dire bon
bah on va essayer de
essayer de comprendre il y va de votre
intérêt et c'est à on discutait et
parfois ça désamorçait et donc ça
permettait la poursuite de cette aide
humanitaire voilà une bonne raison la
drogue ensuite dont vous poser la
question la drogue alors il faut savoir
que les vivats campagne que les les
talibans ne sont pas les inventeurs de
la drogue les inventeurs de la drogue ce
sont ces les pakistanais et la cia et ça
remonte à l'époque des moudjahidine la
révolte contre les contre les russes et
le gouvernement l'afghanistan est devenu
premier producteur de drogue dans le
monde à ce moment là c'est ça a commencé
à ce moment là puis ça n'a fait que
s'accentuer avec le temps mais achetant
l'aca a déjà pris des proportions très
importantes
et pourquoi parce que finalement
abandonné la cia disait ben écoutez aux
pakistanais vous financez vous n'avez
qu'à faire un peu de trafic de drogue ça
vous achètera le matériel militaire
parce que c'était évidemment une guerre
très coûteuse donc les habitudes ont été
prises c'est devenu une affaire un peu
internationale à travers le pakistan à
travers certains militaires pakistanais
disons le aussi et services de
renseignement et tout une affaire qui
n'a fait que s'accentuer au cours des
deux années les talibans par essence la
même manière qu'ils sont des
nationalistes qui sont des puritains qui
sont ils se veulent tueur
selon gravette j'ai dit à l'ats leur
interprétation du grand il n'a pas été
très difficile parce qu'ils avaient
hérité de cette situation de drogue des
moudjahidine qui avait continué
allègrement parce que aussi financer
leur guerre comme ça et leur mon bas
mais les taliban il n'a pas été
difficile de les convaincre d'abandonner
la culture du pavot et deux ans après
leur accession au pouvoir mettre un
terme et abandonne lisa ils ont éradiqué
et d'une façon qui peuvent leur talent
ils peuvent le refaire ils peuvent le
refaire mais vous il faut deux des
ressources je suivais siégea parle pas
avec eux si on leur coupe tout les
vivres les vivres si on leur interdit
d'accéder pour les besoins il faut
contrôler évidemment la façon dont ils
utilisent l'argent et pour des besoins
humanitaires en particulier sur notre
gérant leur interdit tout et qu'on les
sanctionne à nouveau qu'est ce qui va se
passer non seulement ils seront obligés
de continuer avec la drogue mais encore
il risque de se radicaliser et il ce
n'est pas notre intérêt donc il s'agit à
la fois avec 200 g au peuple avant mais
il s'agit de songer aux intérêts de
l'occident et en particulier aux nôtres
mais monsieur l'ambassadeur dell 2 dès
les premières lignes de votre livre vous
êtes très dur avec les américains les
américains ont dit mais tu vous le dites
plus de 1000 milliards en 20 ans dans
l'économie afghane par leur présence par
le rapport est catho fait de cet argent
mais l'argent 50 milliards par an
l'argent si énorme l'argent s'est perdue
dans les sables mouvants il y à des
hausses et plein de sous-entendus ce que
vous dites là mais c'est non c'est la
corruption des élites c'est très simple
tous ces anciens moudjahidine qui était
que les talibans avaient délogé 20 20
ans avant on apprend revenus ils sont
revenus dans autour du pouvoir à
grenouiller et elle n'a pas construit
d'autoroute on n'a pas construit
d'équipement collègues à lui il ya eu
des infrastructures bien sûr il y en a
une partie qui est qui s'est investi il
ya beaucoup d'argent qui est parti dans
l'immobilier mais beaucoup d'argent à
dubaï et ailleurs c'est surtout là que
le gros argent a été recyclé
fortune il n'y avait pas de grosses
fortunes afghane autrefois et c'est
maintenant depuis ces vingt dernières
années que neptune se sont constitués
des fortunes qui vont jusqu'à 1 milliard
200 millions de dollars pas mal de gens
au ce genre d'argent et avec un luxe
ostentatoire etc et c'était de l'argent
des communes de les commissions des
américains c'est comme ça et aussi
d'ailleurs des autres et le chant
faut-il tirer de 2,7 la façon dont les
américains ont géré cette crise
on voit bien que les américains se
découragent aujourd'hui de leur aventure
au moyen-orient au sens large et on
comprend qu'ils se découragent pas ce
qu'ils réussissent en général si mal
parce qu'ils ont du mal à concevoir un
monde qui leur est si étrange et il
pense que ce sera pour ce monde un
bienfait merveilleux que de recevoir les
enseignements d'un système à
l'américaine dont il croit qu'il s'agit
de démocratie parfaite
or elle n'est pas facilement pénétrable
dans des esprits ou depuis des milliers
d'années tout se décide au niveau de
cette micro mosaïque d'un peuple
sectionnés en fragments tribaux ouais
c'est comme ça marc meyer bass il ya des
grands voisins qui sont en train de se
préparer qui ont bien senti qu'il y
avait une place à prendre je pense
notamment à la chine on peut pas choisir
la russie mais le désengagement
militaire des états unis ne doit pas
nécessairement signifier que
les etats-unis ne seront pas
bienveillant ou attentif à l'avenir la
situation afghane ils peuvent aussi
prendre conscience les choses de toute
façon elles ont raté c'est une
frayeur comme on dit en anglais et mais
ils peuvent aussi revenir ouvrir une
ambassade et avoir des relations
d'ailleurs john l'a fait savoir lors de
sa dernière intervention mais évidemment
lorsqu'il ya un vide oui un vide
politique invite géopolitique il y a les
puissances calearo nantes et les
puissances dominantes du moment les
puissances les plus impérial qui tendent
à s'y investir à s'y engouffrer lui
risque du terrorisme il il est réel ou
pas c'est la grande angoisse c'est
l'inquiétude non seulement des
occidentaux mais également de dae des
pays voisins je pense que le risque
terroriste
existera si nous ne diago dialoguons pas
si l'ensemble communauté internationale
ne dialogue pas avec les talibans je
pense que là on a un risque de dérive et
que si en revanche on prend langue avec
eux et que petit à petit on construit
des choses en montrant les lignes rouges
en définissant des ambitions
compatible avec leur idéologie c'est à
dire je pense qu'ils peuvent très bien
lâcher du lest sur la question des
femmes ils peuvent très bien il avait
commencé d'ailleurs il ya dix jours on
n'entendait que les filles pourraient
porter un fichu ou un petit voile ou
continuer d'aller à l'université aller à
l'université à travailler c'est fermé on
va les prendre on va on va les prendre
au mot alors attendons qu'ils aient mis
leurs gouvernements en place mais
actuellement il n'y a pas de
gouvernement il n'y a pas de
gouvernement mais monsieur l'ambassadeur
qui peut mener ces négociations qui peut
porter cette voie que vous décrivez tous
ceux qui ont des contacts avec eux c'est
notre cas au meurent là pour des
questions monétaires je mets ce que la
france a suffisamment de crédits est ce
qu'elle a suffisamment de force est-ce
que c'est pas l'europe plutôt ce serait
beaucoup mieux moi je suis très partisan
du fait qu on est plus forts à 27
qu'avec seul et lorsque j'étais à kaboul
et j'étais le seul diplomate occidental
parce que la france souhaitait justement
conservez dialogue un dialogue ténue 1
mais tout de même parce que je parlais
aussi aux autres je parlais à massoud je
parlais beaucoup à l'entourage de mme a
soudain n'oubliant pas ça
et donc si nous étions plus nombreux à
traiter la question avec eux je pense
que nous serons beaucoup plus
opérationnels dont vous parlez de
massoud le commandant oui vous
connaissez son fils celui dont on
reparle un petit peu qu'ils seraient
dans la montagne en train d'essayer de
reconstituer une résistance oui bon ben
c'est malheureusement une cause un peu
perdue d'avancé parce que là aussi il
faut regarder la géographie faut
regarder d'abord l'histoire et la
géographie et combiner les deux sur le
plan historique massoud le père est un
grand stratège militaire un héros de
l'insurrection contre les soviétiques
il a été ensuite très remarquable dans
sa lutte et perdu contre les talibans il
avait avec lui tout de même beaucoup de
commandants de du nord et il avait les
ouzbeks avec le dostum il avait rallye
et hazara qui étaient avec lui à un
moment donné puis après ils ont été
vaincus il il avait aussi deux provinces
au dessus de la vallée du panjshir qui
dont les commandants lui était acquis
donc c'était une véritable fléau le nom
même est une icône le de long est une
légende le mandat c'est plus une légende
d'une réalité est aujourd'hui donc la
situation est la suivante le panchir est
une jolie grande-vallée ces grands à peu
près comme le luxembourg enfin voila
c'est un très petit territoire très
fertile très beau très magique le nom du
commandant massoud et admirable cette
tête une personne admirable a beaucoup
d'égards son fils via de londres il est
jeune
les anciens vont le respecter à cause de
son père les jeunes ou 110 d'autres
chats à fouetter il ya des gens qui se
sont réfugiés voulant rendre les armes
mais comme les vallées du nord les
reprographes nord sont coupés parce que
les taliban l'occupent et ils ont pris
tous les commandants de ce son rallye à
eux dans ces régions là comme il ya donc
un possibilités d'approvisionnement
depuis le depuis la république depuis le
tadjikistan en particulier sauf par pas
par hélicoptère et ça ça ne va pas ça ne
convient pas et que les talibans
désormais en cercle à vallée du panjshir
il n'y a plus aucune échappatoire pour
cette cause qui est une cause romantique
mais qui n'a pas d'avenir gilberto suis
obligé de vous arrêter on vous écouterai
encore des heures entières raconter un
peu ce que vous savez de de ce pays je
rappelle que votre livre son lait
déjeuner avec les talibans révélations
d'un diplomate de vision saint simon ça
sort actuellement en librairie vous y
raconter un peu votre expérience ce que
vous savez de deux de ces gens de ces
pop de ces peuples et puis de ce que
vous avez appris de ceux de ce pays ce
qu'il peut devenir aussi hélas c'est
important je rappelle que cette émission
est bien on peut la retrouver bien sûr
sur la chaîne en rediffusion bien sûr en
replay sur les réseaux sociaux et puis
sur le site internet arte france point
tv merci encore à très bien merci à vous
[Musique]